oscuridad contra grandeza anarquía
contra el imperio de la ley así fue como
el vicepresidente estadounidense
presentó las elecciones de noviembre
asegurando que el país no prosperará si
los demócratas ganan la presidencia
déjenme ser claro la violencia debe
parar ya sea en minneapolis portland o
kim o ya tendremos ley orden en las
calles de este país para cada
estadounidense de cada raza credo y
color el funcionario defendió a la
policía y cargó contra yobái del
candidato oficial demócrata
doblaría las políticas que llevan a la
violencia en las ciudades la cruda
verdad es que no estarán seguros en los
estados unidos de bay del ahora con el
presidente trump siempre estaremos del
lado de las autoridades y no
desfinanciar hemos a la policía ni ahora
ni nunca
otro de los momentos de la noche estuvo
marcado por el discurso de la asesora
del jefe de estado william conway quien
dejará el cargo a fin de mes en el que
una mujer en un cargo líder puede
parecer una novedad pero no para el
creciente trump durante décadas ha
elevado a las mujeres a importantes
puestos en negocios y gobierno él confía
en nosotras nos consulta respeta
nuestras opiniones e insiste en que
estamos en pie de igualdad con los
hombres
por internet trump volvió a aparecer en
la convención un día antes de la jornada
en la que se espera su discurso de
aceptación como candidato oficial
republicano
el encuentro se cerrará este jueves en
medio de la convulsa situación que vive
el país luego de que se desatara la
última ola de protestas por violencia
policial tras los hechos ocurridos en
kenosha wisconsin en los que agentes le
dispararon en repetidas ocasiones a un
afroestadounidense